when we first got the email about the
movie it was just it was just an idea at
first and they had all the songs and
they had like you know the premise of
what it was but none of us really knew
or had seen it come to life yet and
that's the Zachman moana very much is
the hero of her own story and she's she
kind of found is herself and challenges
other people and it's very much a story
about exploring outside of what you're
used to and being able to do that and
seeing a female do that is I think a
really big step especially sounds like
art is imitating life
Alessia Cara is certainly her own
biggest champion forging a very
successful music career without
compromising her beliefs and integrity
it's not like I question things just to
be a rebel I question them because you
know I say that there's something wrong
with just society's views in general and
so I'm gonna continue to talk about them
and to do what I want to do and hope
that it brings a positive outcome it's
been a wild year for a last year with
her debut album know it all breaking
into the top 10 to the Billboard 200
chart and while she's still churning out
hits she's already looking ahead to her
next record I think I definitely want to
explore different genres that I love and
I think now on my second album I have
more freedom as an artist to do so so I
think I'm gonna just explore a bit of
different genres but still keep it me
because that's just where I fit the best
so we'll see what happens you never know
I could come out with like a rap album
oh my good today so with all this
newfound fame she's kind of have some
famous friends on speed-dial right
I do have Drake's number and he told me
once that when I covered hotline bling a
long time ago he's like great job so
that was that was cool but I don't know
I don't really have many famous people's
numbers in my phone I don't know I don't
talk to people